Jonathan motley has been playing well
the camp it is great to see the
opportunities the a lot of the counters
off to the double teams were promised to
the opposite but then there's a lot of
driving out mariana vetch again Reed
asked to play live to get that wrong but
look right here look out here his left
foot is on the ground and he's still too
real good
jallat Evans but quite a bit up here
distant robotic you just stand it throw
it down
William Bobby oh my goodness he did not
jump hook that put four to go Brisbane
go on the hard way here against Denver
Louie William the bass
[Music]
that's good basketball safe don't just
Alexander's
[Applause]
clean was 54 53 in the past there for
thousands and the Duquette
[Music]
Vauban has it got the shot block away
hard zena's have blocked that focu
spin mr. shott got his rebound and
powered up dunk dog is home runs plays
man you don't eat up Robinson missing
and mobi dunks bucket will pull bond
just in the right spot
[Applause]
announces obviously love him he is
something he's a big a part of the
reason for this is such a rookie
[Applause]
beat the giant
team points shouldn't George LaVon dare
to block it great block hereby probe on
playing volleyball
Beverly
gets it back the givers ago all the gold
they cut them down to 11 that 41 to go
in the period
[Music]
these revelations
well botnets it and stuff see this
amazing route 2 minutes and 51 seconds
to go in the half
keep saying how much this game reminds
me of the game in Brooklyn the bank man
my Olivet again with three unselfish
play by Lou Williams called on sky with
just a great pass there - Hank the
Achilles soreness but he start to heat
up
and there's always long ago birth 200
wins it's the law
inside the tee for the defense using the
creative ball handling wizardry to get
it to vauban young
5ob looks disgust being chased by
caspari's supermen students going to
face another nice role the goal a good
fine Miami [ __ ] is in the score book
see Lou Williams growing so much
attention there's nothing you can get a
good contestant a bump on the shot and
he still knocks it down
but if you make devil's Booker work that
hard all night long to cook it will be
successful call me against another one's
[Music]
inside the bulking in traffic he'll
throw at them that's what you supposed
to do boat boy you attack the rim he's
gonna get the ball of both of their
hands
[Applause]
like my suitcase is away I looked at
this schedule and as soon that this
would be a very tough stress for the
Clippers selfless basketball throw it
down
Pickthall at four or five footer down
steel turns the corner but doesn't take
the ball with him
Jill's just Alexander wide open Bradley
3-ball rims out both the net stop sir
[Applause]
he has 11 on the Sacramento Kings 61
here comes Bobby put the Laker game a
long time link he's one of the better
games that they played my out of it he's
number quick with your town to take part
in a little bit of time you don't miss
41 games in this league and come back
and find the rhythm immediately say with
your chest bovine this is real flip go
up right right now ah pretty ironic
slams at home on the give and go okay
that's the height the pick-and-roll
basketball come back off it and we are
told is available coming back from a
three they so cover for Sinan
Vauban Mariana [ __ ] turning garbage
into gold
some guys have stepped up like
Richardson his computer but it's
basically the same team by the way
Simmons delivering on a rope - Mariana
[ __ ] who is yet to miss a shot they'll
find you then obviously as always with
his head up
mixers would have to rush to try to get
two for one Mariana that's well done
you know the Sixers are learning if you
can get it - Mariana [ __ ] inside
chances are some Goods gonna happen
Kendrick Williams is out there lawless
Stanley Johnson Sixers come up with a
turnover Redick pulls up for a three
Mariana van Zeller it back
buh-bye large part of his career hitting
three-pointers has okay one
Vauban once get it to him in Eretz
Denton Texas at that time barely getting
off the floor and slamming for to him
anyway but he's certainly coming out of
the game now James Ennis look at it
dumps out Brown going heavy bench here
by his Harrison shot at the only starter
is vauban mariana Mitch watching Giles
to our subject earlier he's that way and
the two good buddies combining their I
was taking a boudin
slamming France to Butler the setup of
Mariana bit his own Missa tee throw it
down Vauban Mariana [ __ ] well there's
the nice little dump off from Jimmy
at first he doesn't get it but then hi
only a 30% 3-point shooter he's got 11
off the bench for Minnesota McConnell
has set up but Mariana [ __ ] shoot
properly throws down to just that the
lights appear round as well bo bond with
the exceptional disposition demeanour
Arianna then slamming off of his own
miss Collins swatted it from Simmons
sets Deonte Davis looming as defense
mariana [ __ ] simply picked out of
midair and threw it down
on this
pivot foot somehow minded a Glenn rights
Rony Seikaly guys from that era but none
as important as productive in plain way
the Eastern Conference coming to the
Lakers with dick and feed negotiated
Armitage
PHH with all that talent comes
expectations
fans are still antsy as is depth on top
is a globe on top minute does what boat
by the does pick on the Warriors there
comes Jimmy Butler traveling the space
and then miss the little tip but my
yellow beets
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content